milliarden paket aus dem kanzler abend
die große koalition einigt sich auf neue
abgaben und anreize mit denen
deutschland seine klimaziele erreichen
soll der co2 ausstößt muss dafür zahlen
von den philippinen bis nach kenia
weltweit demonstrieren vor allem junge
menschen für einen besseren schutz der
erde und aufbruch in die akte ist das
forschungsschiff polarstern startet eine
einzigartige expedition ein jahr
eingefroren im nordpolarmeer
[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers guten abend hinein an
einem tag an dem unser planet und die
zukunft des lebens auf der erde im
mittelpunkt der nachrichten steht sport
habe aber natürlich auch gegen ende der
sendung mit robin haben doch von mir
klar ist es wird sich enorm viel ändern
für uns alle es muss sich viel ändern
wenn deutschland seine klimaziele
irgendwie erreichen will
heute war der lang erwartete moment die
bundesregierung hat ihr klimaschutzpaket
beschlossen
es geht um sehr viel geld insgesamt 54
milliarden euro in den kommenden jahren
gucken wir auf die details es wird jetzt
eine abgabe geben für jede tonne co2 im
verkehr und bei gebäuden das heißt zum
beispiel benzin und diesel werden teurer
und neue ölheizungen werden verboten
wie viel der co2 ausstoß künftig kostet
liegt am anfang der stadtfest mit einem
festpreis später soll sich dieser preis
bilden in einem handel mit
verschmutzungsrechten wer viel co2
ausstößt muss sich dabei quasi frei
kaufen
umgekehrt sollen bürger und firmen
entlastet werden etwa bei strompreisen
und über die pendlerpauschale klaus
brodbeck mit weiteren einzelheiten
größer kann der drucker morgen einer
durch verhandelten nacht kaum sein
tausende sammeln sich der klima
protesten im pfarr auf buchstäblich in
letzter minute ringt sich die koalition
dann durch zu ihrem klima paket
es ist nicht so dass wir hier
irgendetwas ideologisches machen sollen
wir machen etwas wofür es so massive
evidenzen gibt dass wir dagegen handeln
müssen und wer diese evidenzen wäre
diese wissenschaftlichen meinung
ignoriert und sagt wir werden schon
irgendwie durchkommen der handelt glaube
ich nicht zukunftsgerecht und das ist
das was uns geleitet hat der
umstrittenste punkt überhaupt der preis
für den ausstoß von co2
er soll ab 2021 von zunächst zehn euro
pro tonne auf 35 euro im jahr 2025
steigen durch dann noch festzulegende
obergrenzen dürfte weiter steigen auf
maximal 60 euro pro tonne
ich glaube also dass das ein sehr
kraftvolles paket ist dass uns viele
viele möglichkeiten schafft dass es in
der lage ist den klimawandel aufzuhalten
und weil wir uns vorgenommen haben immer
wieder zwischendurch nachzuschauen wo
wir stehen wird das diesmal auch besser
gelingen die ziele nicht zu verfehlen
die reaktionen zwiespältig die
automobilindustrie wirkt heute beinahe
erleichtert
insgesamt glaube ich ist es ein gutes
paket geworden mit deutlichen akzenten
bei der förderung der elektromobilität
beim ausbau der ladeinfrastruktur und
auch bei der co2 bepreisung so dass ich
glaube dass der verkehrssektor im
nächsten jahrzehnt zur co2 reduzierung
deutlich beitragen wird die afd die als
einzige partei im bundestag bezweifelt
dass der klimawandel vom menschen
gemacht wird kritisiert das paket
es wird alles teurer für unternehmen für
den verbraucher für den steuerzahler
ich kann mich nicht daran erinnern dass
es jemals im wahlkampf 2017 thema
gewesen wäre
und das heißt wir gerade sehen sind rein
plan sozialistische planwirtschaftlicher
eingriffe in die marktwirtschaftlichen
mechanismen die grünen dagegen sichtlich
enttäuscht über die beschlüsse der groko
wenn es bei diesem paket bleibt dann
besteht keine chance die
klimaschutzziele 20.30 einzuhalten
und deshalb muss ganz dringend deutlich
mehr passieren
die ermatteten verhandler hoffen auch
auf ein signal an die demonstrierende
junge generation grunde genommen müssen
wir all denen die in den letzten monaten
demonstriert haben uns das bewusstsein
gerufen haben danke sagen es ist ein tag
der sicherlich nicht schlecht für das
klima und für den klimaschutz ist und
ganz sicherlich nicht schlecht ist für
das klima innerhalb dieser koalition
heißt wohl für die demonstrierenden
wahrgenommen haben ihre botschaft jetzt
alle ob auch verstanden man muss sehen
auf die politik gucken wir gleich noch
mal genauer erstmal auf darauf wo wir
herkommen beim klimaschutz wo wir stehen
und wo wir hin wollen da wird sauer hat
die übersicht und zeigt auch die gründe
warum dieses land seine ziele bislang
verfehlt
die klimaschutz ziele beziehen sich auf
den treibhausgasausstoß 1990 durch die
modernisierung der ddr industrie gab es
anfangs gute fortschritte
seit zehn jahren stagniert der
treibhausgas-ausstoß die ziele 55
prozent einsparungen bis 2030
und 80 prozent einsparung bis 2050 sind
weit entfernt
warum sehen wir den gesamtenergiebedarf
deutschlands an
er umfasst alle energieträger also kohle
öl gas kernenergie sonne und windkraft
zwar wird die wirtschaft
energieeffiziente aber sie wächst
kontinuierlich der bedarf ist deshalb
seit 1990 nur minimal gesunken
den großteil machen verkehr und wärme
aus nur ein fünftel geht in die
stromversorgung den bedarf decken
unverändert überwiegend fossile
brennstoffe sie sind die hauptquelle des
co2 ausstoßes klimaneutrale
energiequellen also erneuerbare und
kernkraft decken noch immer nur etwa 20
prozent unseres energiebedarfs volker
andreß bei uns aus unserer zdf.umwelt
redaktion verbundenen namen wie weit
bringt uns das was die bundesregierung
da jetzt vor ort also es gibt niemanden
der jetzt sagen würde das ist es jetzt
und 20.30 machen wir eine punktlandung
und kriegen die klimaschutzziele hin
aber es ist ein echter einstieg viele
viele türen sind jetzt auf um eben in
den einzelnen sektoren in den
klimaschutz deutlich stärker als bisher
einzusteigen das ist glaube ich das
große plus was wir jetzt im moment sehen
allein was fehlt ist so eine art
garantie wer sagt eigentlich dass man
wirklich bis 2030 diese maßnahmen
kontinuierlich umsätze und eben bei
dabei bedarf wirklich verschafft
momentan hat man gesagt das macht das
klima kabinett die passen sozusagen auf
sich selber auf das ist mir ehrlich
gesagt zu wenig dann müsste ein bisschen
mehr passieren ich möchte schon die
garantie haben dass die maßnahmen
kontinuierlich umgesetzt werden wenn man
sich die maßnahme im detail anguckt da
ist viel dabei dass unser handeln quasi
steuern soll durch verbote in dem es
teurer wird sind dann aber auch anreize
dabei neue optionen neue alternativen um
klimafreundliche erleben zu können ja
zum beispiel gibt es fördermaßnahmen
neue fördermaßnahmen um städte
umweltfreundlicher zu machen also gelder
um zum beispiel radwege nach vorne zu
bringen auszubauen den öffentlichen
personennahverkehr zu ertüchtigen es
gibt auch neue gelder für die bahn ist
ja auch dringend nötig schienenausbau
man braucht neue züge
das ist schon alles an gedacht es gibt
sogar einen zuschlag beim wohngeld zehn
prozent mehr für den fall dass
wohngeldempfänger
höhere heizkosten zu akzeptieren haben
dann ist ein kleiner ausgleich
geschaffen wirklich sehr sehr viele
einzelpunkte und man kann natürlich
nicht sagen wer davon wirklich
profitiert und wer drauf zahlt das wird
sich im laufe der zeit dann ergeben wir
gucken heute sehr oft deutschland aber
klimaschutz ist natürlich ein weltweites
thema welchen unterschied kann
deutschland machen
naja also zunächst mal müssen ja alle
länder die das pariser klima abkommen
unterschrieben haben ihre hausaufgaben
machen die nationalen klimaschutzziele
müssen erfüllt werden und wir müssen
sogar gegenüber brüssel das ja nachweise
wenn nicht drohen strafzahlungen das ist
das 1
das zweite ist dass natürlich alle auf
deutschland gucken alle das sind die
entwicklungs und die schwellenländer die
sagen warum deutschland reiche ist
industrieland mensch wenn ihr
klimaschutz hinkriegt dann her mit den
konzepten wenn nicht dann machen wir
auch nix also ganz gutes signal
internationales signal positives signal
für die nächste un-klimakonferenz im
dezember in china
die einschätzung von volker angres aus
unserer umwelt redaktion volker
herzlichen dank heute abend das war
lange ein zankapfel in berlin was wir
heute gesehen haben und gleichzeitig war
klar es ist ein projekt das die große
koalition stimmen muss um nicht als
handlungsunfähig zu gelten
gucken wir mal auf den machtpolitischen
teil des heutigen tages mit jack und
alabama dzi in berlin
in welcher verfassung zeigt sich denn
die regierung da also man kann sagen in
einer etwas abgekämpft und das nicht nur
wegen dieser langen durch verhandelten
nachtmann hatte er den großen wurf ja
angekündigt und jetzt wirkt es so als ob
sich beide seiten überlegt hätten dass
sie doch nicht ganz von ihren interessen
lassen wollen das ergebnis ist eines was
heute zumindest ziemlich viel gegenwind
bekommt umweltverbände finden das nicht
gelungen verbraucherschützer beschweren
sich die opposition sowieso und auch
wissen wirtschaftsexperten sagen das ist
nicht ausreichend die einen sagen es zu
langsam und zu lasch die anderen sagen
es ist zu teuer und so ineffizient und
auch aus den eigenen reihen kommt schon
kritik umweltministerin schulze hat hier
schon gesagt die spd hätte sich
eigentlich einen höheren co2 preis
gewünscht also keine große zufriedenheit
am tag selbst und aus dieser großen
kraftvollen geste die man hier setzen
wollte ist jetzt doch eher ein
vorsichtiger schritt geworden das ganze
vor der
bilanz in dieser beschluss mit
einfließen soll mitte oktober
das ist jetzt allerhöchstens eine
atempause für die große koalition aber
kein befreiungsschlag sagte banerji in
einem art abendrot in berlin herzlichen
dank dafür und mehr dazu gibt es in
einem zdf spezial direkt nach uns
klimapaket der groko große wurf oder
heiße luft und natürlich jederzeit auf
heute.de
da finden sie unter anderem einen live
blog mit allen reaktionen auf die
klimapläne der koalition heute morgen
ganz früh das klima kabinett steckt noch
mitten in den verhandlungen da machen
sich überall in deutschland
demonstranten auf den weg um an klima
protesten teilzunehmen
es sind viel mehr als sonst denn die
fridays for future bewegung hat zum ganz
großen streik aufgerufen
in fast 600 orten demonstrieren sie für
den klimaschutz mehr als 70.000 sind es
in hamburg über 100.000 laut polizei in
berlin mit zum teil drastischen bildern
wenn das eis schmilzt soll das hier
zeigen dann geht es für den menschen
nicht gut aus vom tag heute auf
deutschlands straßen berichtet fabian
köhler
sie marschieren für ihre zukunft
gemeinsam mit ihrer klassenlehrerin sind
die sechsklässler der ludwig windthorst
schule in hannover unterwegs
mal durchdringen das unsere welt nicht
einstürzt bevor wir richtig erwachsen
die zukunft der erde an
themenschwerpunkt an der oberschule der
unterricht heute verlagert auf die
straße protest statt pauken
wir haben im religionsunterricht das
thema schöpfung behandelt und da ist
natürlich ein ganz wichtiger aspekt
klimaschutz und um den kindern aus zu
zeigen dass das nicht nur so theorie ist
sondern auch in der praxis haben wir uns
dieser bewegung heute frei der future
angeschlossen
berlin die demonstration viel größer als
erwartet einst schüler bewegung jetzt
raus aus den kinderschuhen
generationsübergreifender aufmarsch
streiken fürs klima längst keine reine
schüler angelegenheit mehr
der handlungsbedarf ist so dringlich
dass wir unseren mitarbeitern tag
freigeben also beziehungsweise nicht
preise und dann die möglichkeit geben
hiermit zu demonstrieren um einfach ein
starkes signal in der öffentlichkeit zu
setzen
ich glaube wirtschaft ohne dass auch an
die zukunft gedacht wird dann
nachfolgenden generationen das
funktioniert nicht mehr
hamburgs innenstadt proppenvoll gut
80.000 menschen verteilen sich rund um
die alster die politischen ergebnisse
aus der hauptstadt für die demonstranten
nicht der große wurf
definitiv nicht aber ich hatte mir noch
nicht erwartet sie treten gekommen weil
ich finde dass ist können sie nicht die
beschlüsse heute für die menschen auf
der straße nur ein erster schritt sie
werden die politik weiter fordern
hunderttausende in deutschland millionen
weltweit in rund 150 staaten streiken
die menschen heute fürs klima australien
indonesien afghanistan kenia und überall
in europa und auch das sind klima
proteste heute auf den salomonen im
südpazifik die zentrale demonstration
soll jetzt in new york beginnen
erwartet wird auch klima aktivisten
gerät atom berg dort haben gut eine
million schüler frei bekommen um sich
den protesten anzuschließen und wie es
zur zeit in new york aussieht der
eindruck von unserem korrespondenten
johannes hano
die frage ist future bewegung hat hier
in den usa bislang keine besonders große
rolle gespielt es gab immer wieder
zwischendurch kleine aktionen aber
nichts koordiniertes und auch als
quitter tonwerk hier ankam bahn mehr
kameras da als unterstützer
das hat sich aber schlagartig geändert
geräte tun bei knapp vor dem kongress
besprochen sie hat dort einige anhänger
gewonnen unter den abgeordneten sehr
viel präsident obama gesprochen und
gesagt dass sie sich nicht mit donald
trump treffen will
das sei verschwendete zeit sollte man
müsse auf der straße druck auf die
regierung ausüben und das elektrisiert
viele amerikaner denn eines darf man
nicht vergessen die meisten amerikaner
62 prozent sehen den klimawandel als
ganz ganz drängt das problem an und mein
persönlicher eindruck ist dass sie jetzt
hoffen mit dieser bewegung hier auch
druck auf ihre regierung ausüben zu
können
johannes hano aus new york in gut einer
stunde startet die größte aktes
expedition aller zeiten
dann legt das deutsche forschungsschiff
polarstern in tromsö norwegen ab
richtung arktis und dort angekommen
lässt das team das schiff einfrieren den
weiteren weg bestimmt die strömung das
nennt sich eis trifft monate lang lassen
sich die wissenschaftler aus knapp 20
nationen so treiben
ihre mission den einfluss des
klimawandels am nordpol erforschen
ostend ali aus tromsö
noch ist der forschungseisbrecher
polarstern im norwegischen tromsö aber
in etwa eineinhalb stunden geht es los
in die arktis auf der suche nach einer
geeigneten eisscholle
dafür hat sie noch knapp zwei wochen
zeit bevor sich die bedingungen
verschlechtern und das eis dicker wird
wissenschaftler testen fieberhaft ihre
systeme wie hier ein hochentwickeltes
radar das was sie hier sehen sie
tatsächlich die berge um das schiff
herum und die wolken
das system zeigt ein dreidimensionales
abbild der atmosphäre eines traktors die
dringlichkeit liegt auf der hand das
arktis eis ist in den letzten 30 jahren
rapide geschmolzen
die daten die auf dieser expedition
gesammelt werden sind grundlagen für
weitere wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse
wie zum beispiel die frage wie dünn ist
denn das eis geworden
im märz nächsten jahres starten an
forschungs flugzeuge zum schiff um
weitere messdaten aufzunehmen das
wichtigste ist aber der klimaschutz die
erkenntnisse sind letztendlich auch die
basis für politische entscheidungen die
zeit drängt so viel in dieser sendung
zum kampf ums klima sich zukunftssicher
aufstellen so nennt die commerzbank das
was sie gerade plant nämlich von ihren
1000 filialen in deutschland 200
schließen das ist jede fünfte und dabei
2300 stellen streichen
noch ist das nur ein konzept des
vorstands aber schon in der kommenden
woche könnte der aufsichtsrat grünes
licht dafür geben
rauchen im auto wenn kinder oder
schwangere dabei sind bislang eine
unsitte vielleicht aber schon bald eine
ordnungswidrigkeit dafür wollen sechs
bundesländer sorgen die ihre initiative
jetzt im bundesrat vorgestellt haben
nach dem vorschlag müssten die
autofahrer dann mit bußgeldern von 500
bis 3000 euro rechnen wie das zu
überwachen ist so ähnlich wie das
handyverbot am steuer
bei verkehrskontrollen schlagen die
länder vor
und damit sind wir beim sport in der
sendung ganz fußball europa league
gestern abend mit einer bösen klatsche
für gladbach die borussen verloren
zuhause mit 0 zu 4 gegen den
österreichischen außenseiter wolfsberger
ac
die höchste heimniederlage gladbachs in
der europapokal-geschichte nach 68
minuten machen sich die fans auf den
heimweg gladbach mit unvermögen und pech
die gäste im angriff in der 13 minute
der erste gegentreffer der zweite nach
einer halben stunde und noch vor der
pause gab es auch noch an tempo
riedmayer 0 zu 3 zur halbzeit ein abend
zum vergessen
wir müssen einfach das spiel nutzen und
wenn man die richtigen dinge draus
ziehen für die nächsten wochen
dann kann das auch für uns in der summe
dann irgendwann mal vielleicht ein spiel
gewesen sein wo richtige entscheidungen
danach getroffen haben wolfsberg erhöhte
in der 68 minute durch leid geht es ist
eine lehrstunde die erste große
belastungsprobe für trainer rose am
neuen arbeitsplatz und auch die
eintracht musste federn lassen verlor zu
hause 0 zu 3 gegen den
europa-league-finalisten fc arsenal
frankfurt mit zahlreichen torchancen und
einer roten karte kurz vor spielende
danach kassierte die mannschaft noch
zwei gegentreffer
einziger lichtblick wolfsburg der vfl
gewann sein heimspiel gegen pfk
alexandria aus der ukraine mit 3 zu 1
vor der allerdings enttäuschenden
kulisse von 10.000 112 zuschauern die
deutsche ringerin anna schell hat bei
der wm in kasachstan bronze gewonnen
die 26 jährige bezwang in der
gewichtsklasse bis 68 kilogramm die
japanische olympia siegerin sara doch
das ist die vierte bronzemedaille für
das deutsche team und deutschlands beste
tennisspielerin angelique kerber hat
beim wta turnier in osaka den zweiten
sieg errungen
die frühere weltranglisten erste setzte
sich im viertelfinale gegen die
us-amerikanerin madison keys durch die
im dritten satz verletzt aufgeben musste
für kerber ist dass nach den vielen
niederlagen der jüngsten zeit die erste
halbfinalteilnahme seit zweieinhalb
monaten
das was von mir
das wetter am wochenende wird sonnig und
warm genauer hinschaut gleich gunther
tiersch heute journal mit der kollegin
marietta slomka um 22 uhr 10 heute und
darin ein gespräch mit dem
bundesfinanzminister und der frage wo
kommt das geld her fürs klima milliarden
paket dazu auch gleich mehr im zdf
spezial mit matthias fornoff wir sehen
uns hoffentlich morgen wieder punkt 7
danke dass sie dabei waren heute in
allen einen angenehmen
[Musik]
und da habe liebe zuschauer hat das
wochenende wird warm und sonnig und
damit fehlt uns natürlich weiterhin der
wichtige regen den wir dringend brauchen
können kommt vielleicht nächste woche
aber zunächst haben wir ein herrliches
hochdruckgebiet stabile wetterlage mit
viel sonnenschein das zieht noch ein
bisschen nach osten und so kann die
luftströmung mehr aus dem süden zu uns
kommen das bedeutet wärme und die wolken
hier an der küste
während sich mehr und mehr auflösen
heute nacht haben die wolken dort noch
da ist es noch stark bewölkt bis zur
ostsee sonst wird klar kalt im süden bis
0 grad im östlichen bayern und
verbreitet gibt es dazu wieder den boden
frost tagsüber wird es aber richtig
angenehm warm selbst an der ost sich 17
grad das ist das kühlste und am wärmsten
wird es im westen niederrhein mose 25
grad das wurde ein sommertag bedeuten
und es ist überall sonnig zum teil
wolkenlos dazu weht im süden und in der
mitte ein kräftiger ost bis südostwind
einen leichten wind habe im norden aus
westen da ist es anfangs sind vorpommern
noch bewölkt nachmittags kommt dann mehr
und mehr die sonne wieder raus der
sonntag wird eigentlich ganz ähnlich
vielleicht noch ein bisschen wärmer dann
allerdings fängt es an zu regnen
viel wird es nicht sein aber vielleicht
im süden und in der mitte 10 oder 20mm
ich wünschen noch einen schönen abend
und machen sie es gut